[Music]
in our previous video we studied that
sound needs a medium for propagation
that is it requires some medium to
travel from one place to another but how
does it really travel through the medium
what happens to the particles of the
medium let us find out we now know that
sound is produced by vibration when the
object is vibrating it sets the
particles of the medium around into
vibration in the process the nearest
particles to the source gets displaced
from the mean or equilibrium position
they start to collide with the particles
adjacent to them the adjacent particles
then also get displaced from their mean
positions they in turn do the same to
the neighboring particles this process
continues in the medium till the sound
reaches R here we see that we create
some disturbance flowing through the
medium this is the way that sound
travels through the medium we see that
particles of the medium are not
traveling from the source to the human
ear it is the disturbance produced by a
source which is traveling in the medium
the particles are merely oscillating
from the mean positions this disturbance
created by the vibrating object in the
medium is what we call a sound wave but
what does this disturbance look like let
us study this with the help of a tuning
fork here we take air as a medium of
propagation here we have a tuning fork
made up of steel this shows the initial
condition of the air particles of the
medium when the tuning fork is in its
original position that is when tuning
fork is not vibrating when we strike it
sprung on a rubber band we start hearing
a sound how does the sound travel
through the medium the two prongs of
tuning fork are vibrating let us
concentrate on motion of one of the
prongs first say the one on the right
when it's away from its mean position it
pushes and compresses the air particles
around it this creates a high
fresher region also called compression
this compression travels in the medium
as a disturbance here the density is
high that is the particles are very
close to each other when the prong comes
towards its mean position the pressure
on the right decreases and keeps on
decreasing further as the prong
continues its motion towards left this
creates a low pressure region also
called as vera faction we see that at
this point the compression in the form
of disturbance has reached this region
this rare faction also travels in the
medium as a disturbance here the density
of particles is less that is the
particles are far away from each other
as it continues to vibrate we get a
series of these compressions and
rarefactions this continuous sequence of
compressions and rarefactions is what we
call sound waves yes the sound waves
travel in the form of compressions and
rarefactions instead of the tuning fork
if we take any other source of sound say
the speaker then the sound waves
generated by this object will also
travel in the form of compressions and
rarefactions here is one interesting
question is the sound wave or mechanical
waves do you know what a mechanical wave
is the mechanical wave is a wave that
requires some material medium to travel
and as we know a sound wave also
requires some medium to travel so yes it
is a mechanical wave how do you define
vacuum can't sound travel through it to
find the answer to these questions you
have to wait for our next video see you
there
[Music]
you